[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings and we
are hearing from a woman suing
facebook's parent company over the
murder of her brother angela underwood
jacobs is challenging a controversial
law that protects social media companies
from liability for things posted on
their networks her brother pat underwood
was working as a federal officer
guarding a u.s courthouse in oakland
california in 2020 when the fbi says he
was shot dead by anti-government
extremists who allegedly met and
organized on facebook in her first
national television interview she
explains why she believes that her
brother would still be alive today if
not for facebook
on the night of may 29 2020 not far from
protests over the murder of george floyd
a surveillance camera captured this
white van outside the federal courthouse
in oakland california investigators say
the vehicle pulled forward as the door
slid open and someone inside opened fire
wounding one federal security officer
and killing another an assassin cowardly
shot
to federal protective service
contractors as they stood watch over a
protest
according to a criminal complaint robert
justice jr drove the van while stephen
carrillo pulled the trigger using the
protest as cover for an anti-government
attack
both men have pleaded not guilty
and yet the world is
a little less better now with him not
being in it
angela underwood jacobs is the sister of
murdered officer pat underwood and she
says there was a third accomplice that
tragic night
facebook if not for facebook do you
think your brother would still be with
us today i do i believe that if facebook
had acted
with the information that they had privy
to that no one else had of course
of course i do
in a new wrongful death lawsuit she
alleges justice and carrillo had never
met in person and had no reason to cross
paths
until a facebook group brought them
together the suit claims the social
media network recommended justice joined
groups dedicated to the extremist
boogaloo movement where the two men
connected and hatched and planned the
attack they had the information that
could have stopped all of this
and they set on it
they choose to not hand over the
information to authorities ted leopold
is her lawyer if facebook were
monitoring that
what makes you comfortable with them
determining what is just people talking
and what is a crime
they know
through their actions of bringing these
extremist groups together
that bad things are going to happen
and they know through their own
algorithms that there are code words
that these groups use
and so i don't think anything that was
happening amongst communications of
these groups
was unknown to facebook but he
acknowledges lawsuits of this kind have
never succeeded against social media
companies because of section 230 part of
a broader 1996 internet law which
protects internet platforms from being
held liable for content posted by users
leopold says that law should no longer
apply to facebook
they don't fit within the guidelines of
section 230 they don't get
to be immunized
by the section so you're saying everyone
thinks that they're protected by
section 230 but from you where you sit
their behavior is so outside of what
that section is intended for that we're
in a different world right because they
provide the content they drive people to
various
groups they bring groups in that
otherwise would not be there but for
facebook actively
bringing them to
their platform
have you heard from facebook not at all
facebook for its part declined our
request for an interview but in a
statement it calls the lawsuit without
legal basis and says it's banned more
than a thousand militarized social
movements from its platform that
includes the bugaloo movement a ban it
announced a month after the murder of
pat underwood it's kind of like they
feel the fire for underwood jacobs that
is the very definition of too little
too late what do you think pat would say
if he knew all the details of what
happened he would tell me
hang on
he would say
have faith
that the right thing will be done
so that
other people
wouldn't lose their lives
the same way that he lost his
so i'm very grateful for angela
underwood coming and talking to us about
this case uh it's going to be a
difficult case for for her illegally but
it's a helpful case for the country at
the moment because republicans and
democrats and mark zuckerberg all want
these liability laws section 230 changed
but the the complicated thing is how
should they be changed at what point at
what point does facebook or any other
social media company become liable for
bringing people together letting those
people plan a bad thing and then that
bad thing happening in the world did
facebook know they were planning a bad
thing that's what i'm confused about
well according to according to francis
uh how can the facebook leaker they know
a lot more than they let on about these
uh uh groups the fact they banned the
group after the fact speaks volumes uh
and the fbi says that the what was
actually communicated on facebook uh was
inflammatory it it had flames and
pictures of dead uh law enforcement uh
and and so that is the question should
they have known did they have enough
should they be liable in these extreme
groups um
they are birthed almost every day so
it's it's almost like finding a needle
in a haystack or something i heard
recently on something we've done um it's
like finding a needle and a stack of
needles oh yeah which is
you know so tough to do yeah but at some
point if you got an amusement park and
they keep throwing rides out because bad
things happen do you go to that
amusement park anymore i don't know
that's a good point yeah you do no
no